and our shoutout tonight for one of the
great champions of investigative
journalism Tom Galloway who passed away
earlier this year a prominent lawyer he
quietly help to support journalists
around the world who were committed to
taking truth to power especially in his
beloved Appalachia where he grew up poor
never forgetting those who remain
trapped in a place or powerful interests
oppress and abuse it was a project that
no 1 news organization had been able to
take on a sweeping indictment of how and
why so many people in America's
Appalachian region had no safe reliable
source of clean drinking water reporters
from three different outlets came
together for the project from the
Charleston Gazette mail my name is Katie
Coyne I'm a reporter at the Charleston
Gazette now West Virginia Public
Broadcasting I'm Molly born I work with
West Virginia Public Broadcasting and
the luck Jensen herald-leader my name is
Will Wright I work for the Lexington
herald-leader this project especially
dives into things that affect people's
daily life you know access to water is
something that many people don't even
think about spending months traveling
across West Virginia and Kentucky water
should be clear and odor
and that's
something we don't have you inhabit for
a very long time if you turn on your tab
and it's white
and it's no luck boring
you know that's not good it was a
journalistic tour de force all made
possible by one wealthy lawyer whose
only credit was a short screen credit at
the end of the video embellishing the
Ganaway Foundation chaired by Tom
Galloway who died earlier this year I
think he really understood poverty I
think he understood some of the really
intense struggles that happen in places
like where he grew up in Appalachia and
he had a very deep sense of wanting to
give back
Charlie Senate runs the ground truth
project that spearheaded the water
investigations Tom understood the power
of journalism from his very earliest
days as a lawyer where he took on big
coal and really went after some of the
companies that were really destroying
the environment and treating people very
unfairly in the communities they were
they were based as a successful lawyer
Galloway was later involved in going
after the misty's at the corrupt energy
company Enron he funded projects about
human rights and LGBT rights in Africa
he followed up on the reporting that
Rhonda Schwartz and I did at ABC News
about the treatment of garment factory
workers in sweatshops in the American
territory of the northern marianas
locked fire exits overheated electrical
panels toilets that don't work what
authorities called flagrant violations
of US labor and safety laws part of a
legal team that later got a 20 million
dollar settlement for some 30,000
workers but Galloway's passion was for
Appalachia where he grew up in poverty
and then first emerged as a lawyer
speaking up for the little guy Tom
really dedicated his entire career to
trying to help those people who are
underserved telling their story became
part of that work journalism became a
critical appendage to all of the legal
work that he did in a way that could
tell a story that he wouldn't
necessarily be able to tell in the
courtroom
Galloway's becky has already helped to
fund major investigations at West
Virginia's leading newspaper The Gazette
Mail and a time the paper was in
financial straits
according to reporter Ken ward Tom
Galloway's legacy for Appalachia is not
just all the litigation he did to bring
bad guys to justice but it's the
journalism that's going to live on for
years and years and years giving people
the kind of information they need about
their community we have two reporters in
our newsroom now that are funded by them
and at a time when advertising revenues
are dropping and it's difficult to keep
staff up that kind of those kind of
resources
two additional reporters one of them
dedicated to covering southern West
Virginian the other one dedicated to
covering poverty issues in southern West
Virginia Galloway was once named trial
lawyer of the Year by a group called
public justice and he lived in a life of
luxury with grand homes in Colorado
Washington DC and Martha's Vineyard but
his wife Kathy says he would have traded
it all to be one of those investigative
reporters he admired so much I think he
was so enamored of the work that you
were able to do Brian and Rhonda who you
would have given us left pinky to be
able to have hospitality you had a
journalism do you still drink your tap
water or is this solely what you drink
not really why not the water project
from ground truth came as Galloway knew
his days might be numbered and he died
though there were Galloway fellows
across Appalachia and elsewhere doing
the work he's so admired he dreams of
having a strong investigative journalism
unit in every newspaper and
I have radio station across America he
was a brilliant storyteller and he would
like to see the most brilliant
storytellers telling the public what's
happening in their communities across
the country but that would that would be
a wish come true for him Tom Galloway
was a strong supporter and a good friend
to me
and our executive producer Rhonda
Schwartz and to so many journalists
around the world he will be missed but
as legacy will continue to the Galloway
foundation in the able hands of his wife
Cathy and daughter Erin that's our
program for tonight thanks so much for
joining us we'll see you right back here
next week on the law and crime Network
you
you